We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P a
here's a funny voicemail and we're going to
do something special for this color.
We're going to do something special when we
come up with a title for the YouTube clip
for this voicemail, take a listen.
Oh Hey, David Pakman, Robby in Los Angeles
to be three.
I can't stand videos that have titles like
shreds, destroys, obliterate, and I know you
title some of your videos that way facetiously.
And that your audience for the most part knows
that.
But I wonder if it doesn't add to this stupidity
online for people who might not know your
show.
For instance, sometimes I've shown my friends
your videos, some of them have the facetious
titling and kind of their eyes and I have
to explain that.
You're kidding.
Right.
Um, so I'm just wondering if you're gonna
keep doing that.
It's not a big deal, but I do think it kind
of adds to the silliness of the online commentary.
Yeah.
So listen, we are going to keep doing it.
If we do it facetiously.
It, I think it came out of the right where
the right started titling videos.
Like, you know, Ben Shapiro destroys feminist
with facts and logic or whatever.
And here's what you have to understand.
I get what you're saying that from a completely
serious point of view, if we're trying to
do serious commentary and we have, you know,
a video called, uh, a Trumpist implodes, uh,
impotently trying to defend Trump or whatever,
there's some fraction of the audience who
might say, Oh, just on the basis of that title,
I'm not taking this seriously.
For the most part, it's just a calculation.
The net benefit of doing that.
Uh, and of course the fact that after you
watch a minute or even 30 seconds, you'll
see, Oh, okay, this is actually, it's just
this is a critique of what, what went on.
Uh, I think it's okay.
And just for you, just for the color, we're
going to title the, your voicemail.
When we upload this to YouTube, we're going
to call this disgusted color obliterates our
YouTube channel.
Um, and you know what?
It'll probably do better than if we simply
called it respectful caller has mild critique
of David Pacman's video titles or something
like that.
But in any case, it's the game.
You know, we, we play the game as it needs
to be played on different platforms.
Our podcast episodes are titled much more
soberly because that's what's expected there.
And that's what seems to do well with the
podcast audience on YouTube.
We play around sarcastically using, you know,
some of the sort of memes that right-wingers
like to use for titles.
It's working fine.
I don't predict we're going to change it anytime
soon.
But notice that with interviews, like when
we interview a professor or something like
that, we don't use the hyperbolic titles,
we just call it, you know, whatever it is
and then put the professor's name.
So I think that we are measured enough with
our titling strategy, but I appreciate the
concern and the support.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
George Zimmerman will just not get out of
the lives of the family members of Trayvon
Martin now suing the family for $100 million
hospital's speaking of loss.
It's all lawsuits today on the bonus show,
hospitals are suing Donald Trump over his
price disclosure rule that he passed.
And then Congressman Devin Nunez is suing
CNN over defamation, alleged for $435 million.
Many lawsuits to discuss on the bonus show
today and more get instant access.
I'm not talking about 20 minutes down the
lot.
Line.
You get instant access by signing up@joinpacman.com
or by becoming a [inaudible]
patron@thefivedollarlevelatpatrion.com slash
David Paxton show.
I'll speak to you then or otherwise.
Tomorrow on the Friday show, the David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].